lebanon is marking the first anniversary
of a massive explosion in the port of
the capital beirut
[Music]
the blast killed some 200 people injured
thousands and flattened large parts of
the city including
shops offices and homes the explosion
was caused by tons of ammonium nitrate
that's a fertilizer
that had been for years improperly
stored at the city's port
much of what was destroyed is still yet
to be rebuilt
one year on lawmakers and security
officials are accused of negligence
calls are growing for the lebanese
parliament to lift their immunity
meanwhile an investigation remains
stalled and families of the victims are
still
waiting for answers about why their
loved ones
had to die dw's rebecca ritters has this
report
sahar ferris loved her job
the young paramedic had finally managed
to break into the nearly all-male world
of the beirut fire department
she was on top of the world she used to
wear the uniform and put mascara
and put lipstick then like she's going
out
i admired her because i was so proud
that i
i have such a great girl and
look for her bravery got
on august 4th 2020 sahar and nine of her
colleagues were called to a fire at the
port
in this video taken by sahar her
colleagues shout out for backup
it seemed routine then this
beirut changed forever
one year on zaha's family are still
searching for answers
they won't come back we know that
but at least for them we want to know
who did this to
them every day every night
you sleep with the pain in your heart
is it is it really one year without her
yes for the families of these victims
moving on without justice is impossible
an ongoing investigation has so far
failed to find any real
answers and efforts to bring those to
account but thought to be responsible
for what happened here
have been hampered by a convoluted
system of political immunity
one year on the same questions remain
how did lebanon
get here how were thousands of tons of
explosive material
able to be stored so close to the city
for so many years
who is to blame and will they ever be
brought to justice
the herti family lost three men their
son shabel
his cousin and his uncle all
firefighters who
like zaha put themselves in danger for
public service
only to be let down by the
representatives of their near-failed
state
here on earth we just want one of the
trees
in heaven i'm sure god will take care of
the rest we're just asking for one
percent of the truth
that's all the justice we need father
has no faith that any progress will come
from inside the country
it's a lost cause our only hope is if
the international community were to help
us with an official investigation
charbelle's mother finds it hard to
speak the family tells us
since losing her son but she keeps his
memory close to her heart
and while the country mourns with her
the flag at half-mast
the wreckage that remains is a constant
reminder of the justice not yet served
joining me now here in the studio asdw's
jafar abdul karim
jafar you've just come back from beirut
where you hosted the latest edition of
your
uh popular talk show jafar talk
you did that right at the harbor as we
can see in the middle of the destruction
there you met other people
that are still looking for justice tell
us about them
i met families who lost their beloved
ones i met
politicians i met activists but the
thing that stays when you come back now
to berlin and you really think about it
is the situation of the people who lost
their beloved ones because till now they
still
don't know who's responsible for losing
their beloved ones
they don't know any new information that
uh
that's a after one year and this makes
you really think
how could this be and uh why is it like
this and this is exactly the questions
they are having now
and the people of berwick would have to
go with a dysfunctional
government what rebecca ritters called a
convoluted system of immunity there in
her story
and a flawed investigation do the
lebanese people think they will ever see
justice
they want and they would love to think
that they will see justice
but according to what i see i saw and
and i
observed and talking to them they also
have a feeling that
there might be no justice because
corruption is very high when it comes
to lebanon according to transparency
international and when we take a very
concrete example the
the leading investigator judge bittar
requested some high officials
and till now they are not lifting the
immunity so they can
talk to them and investigate and this is
a very concrete
example that maybe justice will not be
happening one day in in lebanon for this
concrete explosion
and and what you also see that people
don't give up they're still going to the
streets but if i compared to one year
ago
it's not the same energy it's not the
same power
it's not the same will what i felt and
what i
saw is people are somehow like
losing hope tired out
yes probably you were embarrased right
after the blast and then
several times since then is that what
has changed that people
really seem to have lost hope beside
losing hope we're looking now at the the
at the at the
airport and we see what's happening and
from from the perspective
we're seeing now is what's happening
after the explosion
but there's also a life behind that
the daily life no electricity maybe some
hours if you know why medicaments for
your child you don't find the right
thing
milk is not also available if the the
amount that you need
even if you look at basic things that
you would like to have
it's vegetables also not available and
maybe very very
expensive and if you want to just tank
fuel for your car you wait for hours
and this is the simply daily life basics
you need in your everyday life and this
is getting to be a challenge and so you
can imagine
how life is now in beirut in lebanon so
do you see any
any chance that sort of the people who
are now very very tired with everything
that they will force change in some way
they i mean if there's no change they
will suffer even more and this is going
to be the question is it
is it for me after being in lebanon is
the
question the will of the people or is it
a very high corrupted
political system that need to be changed
and how is this gonna happen because
people have been protesting and
demonstrating since years
but if we look to the facts there's no
change happening on a political
system and political system according to
organization
is the problem because it's corrupted
there's
maybe one small hope next year
there are going to be elections and so
the people can vote and maybe decide
who they want in the political system
curry thank you very much thank you and
of course
to our viewers you can watch the current
edition of jafar talk on dw's
arabic service and of course on youtube
i highly recommend it
specialists from german maritime
logistics company combilift inspect
chemical remains stored in beirut port
after nearly 3 000 tons of ammonium
nitrate exploded there a year ago
laying waste to the heart of the city
and killing hundreds
the containers and barrels that survived
still posed a threat
with many damaged some were potentially
explosive
others highly toxic since combilift got
to work
it's removed and disposed of 59
containers
it took us six months in order to clean
the support of the chemicals and
and to make them safe again for the
transportation
um and uh no we we uh we did our job
everything is already in germany and
went through the disposal the job is
done it's finished
so it took us in total 10 months of
operations
eventually beirut will be rebuilt but
not before the cleanup is finished
half a million cubic meters of debris
and scrap are still lying around here
riddled with chemicals combilift is in
talks with the lebanese government for
the contract to remove this debris as
well
it wouldn't cost the struggling country
anything the company says selling the
cleaned wreckage as scrap metal would
cover its costs
it also says it's up to politicians to
prevent a repeat
we all know that the port was misused
for many years
as a storage area which which is not the
normal use of a port
uh it should be import and export um so
i think it's more political issue and
and
that would should be at rest and and
should be changed for good in the future
sparked by welding work the explosion
left over three hundred thousand
homeless and seventy thousand
jobless housing hospitals and schools
were devastated along with the economy
a year later inflation is at 50 percent
and thousands still struggle to feed
themselves
now the problems facing the people of
lebanon a year after the explosion seem
overwhelming but as our special
correspondent rebecca ritters reports
now
there are also moments of hope such as
the birth of little baby george
who took his first breath just one hour
after the deadly blast
little does baby george know he was born
under the most unusual circumstances
a looming pandemic an unprecedented
economic collapse
and in the midst of the biggest
non-nuclear explosion in history
his father edmund recounts with me the
story of the day he was born
he captured it all on video i kept
recording i don't know
emmanuel was wheeled into the delivery
room
and then
survival mode one hour and ten minutes
later
baby george was born
these videos soon went viral and george
became a symbol of hope
for a country reeling from an
unthinkable disaster
[Music]
but all that seems a world away in his
happy family home on the outskirts of
beirut
on that day we were lucky like we were
one of the
only people in lebanon or few people in
lebanon that were really lucky
we went in with seven people and we came
out with eight
edmond and emmanuel are more than aware
of the problems facing their country on
top of the trauma a lack of certainty
about where their country is headed
makes life harder
but these new parents are choosing to
stay positive for their baby boy
since having george george was our only
only hope since after the
explosion so we had to give him a good
time
it's not his fault that what we went
through
so we're not ready to give him a bad
side of life we're going to show them
the good side of life
for now hope is all the family have as
they look out to a lebanon with an
uncertain future
you